so in the quran we've got allah swearing
by
literally uh everything
we'll be talking about that a little in
a few moments um
given that we find these things in the
muslim sources
i'm truly interested in how we can sit
here and poke fun
at the doctrine of the trinity now the
real basis i find uh for
reconciling these texts with the
doctrine of tawheed
is that muslim scholars don't let you
know this stuff which is why you think
it's funny
when you're hearing it time is up dr
wood
now we're going to start our second part
which is the the 12-minute rebuttal and
going first is mr mohammed hijab you can
go ahead
i think david would have said some
career-ending embarrassing statements
today i mean
to be honest with you
after 20 years of researching islam you
come with this
okay let's deal with one one by one
it says allah says
and he's here saying that he prays to
the prophet
there's a difference between us
in the arabic language i knew this was
going to happen i knew this was gonna
happen
i knew i was gonna have to give you a
free arabic lesson here today
i knew it and that's why the translators
put
four not two the prophet
you don't know what the words in arabic
mean don't speak salah
come on please don't embarrass yourself
allah has parts
he says muslim scholars say we should
take this literally
which muslim scholars which muslim
scholars
he says
chapter 20 of the quran means everything
is destroyed except for his face
and this means that allah all his body
parts will be destroyed and he has body
parts in these things
first of all the word kul in arabic
doesn't necessarily mean all
subkey wrote a book and he said
and he shows with examples that the word
doesn't mean all i'll give an example in
chapter 46 of the quran
everything was destroyed except for the
houses if it meant every single thing it
wouldn't have been the houses would not
be there so the word kul doesn't mean
that in arabic language once again
it's a problem with language
he says that this is exactly his words
he said the quran is eternal person
tell me one scholar in the history of
islam who said that this is a lie
he says the quran is a
you have to it will come as a shafia on
the day of judgment so if this is the
question
i'll put it better for you i'll help you
yeah if the quran is an attribute of god
how can it intercede for you this is
what he's saying right
it's a good question this is a good
question but it's not a proper
understanding of the hadith this is
the only good question you had i'll give
it to you this is the only good question
you had
the hadith says
so it's not that the quran i.e the
attribute of allah that will intercede
for you on the day of judgement
but it is your of the quran and the the
web that you get of the quran which
means the reward you get from the
recitation of the quran not the quran as
an attribute of allah
he says therefore there's 114 persons of
the quran two quran fallacy
two kokui fallacy i told you he would do
it an appeal to hypocrisy
so here are you admitting that having
more than one person of a being
of god is wrong because you should lead
to trinitarianism then
but obviously as we know there's no one
in the history of islam that referred to
the surah of the quran
as persons this is wrong you don't know
about islam here you're being educated
he said well he didn't know the arabic
but i'm going to give him the
arabic in chapter six verse hundred
eight of the quran says
that allah did not have a mate so does
this mean what does this mean
that biological they had a discussion
about biological really and truly
how can you have a begotten son there's
only three options number one
biology number two adoption and number
three metaphor
and if you say it's not biology and it's
not adoption it must be a metaphor so
jesus is not a son of god
[Music]
okay and then he says that the prophets
they they played you know they tried to
get his hair and the spit and these
things okay well if you think
spitting when someone makes you a god
well that's what it implies and i wonder
why
you look at every other verse of the
bible as implying that jesus was god
because
for you a spit
that's that's making me a god now
[Music]
i mean don't embarrass yourself
in front of me
he said this means that he's interceding
because it's a narrative voice
we say this in the shahid every time
it's a narrative voice
however let's not say it's a narrative
voice let's give it to him he says
this must mean that the prophet muhammad
is omnipresent yes
he's omnipresent let's let's have fun
with him today
there is a hadith in bukhari which says
that whenever one person does salah on
the nebi which means
blessings and praise on the the prophet
blessings on the prophet
the angel will carry that and give it to
him
it doesn't mean that he's hearing it
everywhere the angel is moving it around
this is from the will of allah and if
you didn't know that
now you do he says
that kalimatullah the eyes are being
referred to as the word of allah
must mean that he is divine so although
the quran says clearly that he's not
divine no it makes a mistake he is
divine well
you're all over the place you're
fumbling all over the place it's
embarrassing
is defined in chapter 3 verse 58 of the
quran
says
five minutes left he said to him be and
he was the word is defined in the quran
as be so allah says be and things are
just like he said be with adam he said
be with jesus
and he was he says that there are seven
uh planetary things in arabia and these
things i mean how can you make
a a judgment first of all i haven't got
a reference for that
i didn't see a referee didn't say yes
i'll give you a reference here it says
bukhari whatever even if he's got a
reference
how do you know that the practice
originated from that and not from
abraham
after all abraham even in the old
testament
yes he existed pre-existed before jesus
even though you have you know the
physical jesus and he was there in the
desert
and you have in the book of psalms
mention of pilgrimage so if this is the
case
then i wonder why this is mentioned now
this is i think this is all that he kind
of mentioned
i want to give you one principle ladies
and gentlemen that will destroy
everything he said the quran says
chapter 42 verse 11.
that there's nothing like him you cannot
do tashbee
or tempthil of allah anything that we
see in the quran
talking about the hand talking about the
face all of these things
you can rest assured because of this
verse and the other verse
that this means yes this means it cannot
be compared to anything you imagine
in the quran anyways i mean every muslim
know this but the idea
is there's implicit admission here that
i've lost
this is this is what i come up with i've
lost yes we know trinitarianism is so
confusing but i'm going to show you how
much
you know hate is confusing as well i
have admitted defeat
therefore i'm going down i'm going down
i'm gonna try and take you down with me
that's that's really what you're trying
to say to me david wood i know by the
look of your face here
you would probably agree with me let's
be honest look at his face everyone
ladies and gentlemen
take a look at his face yes anyways i've
got
a few minutes left let me recite some
quran because i've done with this guy
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he says in
chapter number 19 verse number 31
about jesus this is what we believe
about jesus
l
foreign
this is what allah says in the quran
listen to it tell me if this is not a
better model for you
be honest this is jesus he says i am the
slave of allah
of god he gave me the book and he made
me a prophet
just like in chapter eight of mark
verse one minute left yes 48
people thought jesus was a prophet in in
the old testament in the new testament
in the time of jesus when he was alive
and he made me blessed wherever i am
this is what we believe of jesus
he made me blessed wherever i am you
know
what al-sanib is he was zakati
and he told me to pray and to give
charity so long as i am alive
you know this is what we believe about
jesus christ
validity i was good with my mother well
i wasn't an arrogant person
and peace be upon me the day i was born
and the day i die and the day i will
come back to life
that is jesus son of mary the one who
you definitely
before we start on